merci
je ne sais pas si vous l'avez remarqué
mais nous avons tous tendance à vouloir
rentrer dans des cases et surtout à y
ranger les autres
nous cherchons à nous
conformer une certaine faut surtout une
forme de cohésion face à la
conformité alice et notre image
mais que faire de ces cases
est ce qu elle nous rassure
est ce qu'elle nous enferme
commence arrangement avec ce paradoxe
qui est
être comme tourner
et en même temps être soi
alors de ces injonctions nouvelle
soyez vous même
les autres sont déjà pris
est ce à dire accepte la différence car
elle te rend unique et c'est vrai
mais est ce que cette différence
elle vous permet d'être acceptée et
reconnue par les autres
je me suis longtemps demandé dans quelle
case je rentrais
je suis blanche mon nom de famille est
sénégalais et la moitié de ma famille et
noir
quand j'étais petit et que j'allais en
vacances au sénégal chez mon grand père
guy down à dakar et que je disais à mes
copains d'école où j'allais on me disait
mais et les noirs
oui et les
ça pose la question de l'appartenance au
groupe ethnique
de l'identité
de votre place aussi dans la société
pourtant malgré cette particularité
d'identité je partais avec une très
bonne case
un père militaire de carrière
une mère au foyer
propriétaires de leur grande maison
et une bibliothèque en chêne massif dans
le salon
mais dans le secret de ma famille il y
avait la détestation de ma mère
et elle n'était satisfaite
que lorsqu'elle avait réussi à
convaincre mon père ne me corriger dès
son retour du travail
alors à son arrivée il me disait cette
phrase
montre dans ta chambre
déshabille toi j'arrive
et je devais me mettre nue à plat ventre
et j'attendais les coups de ceinturon
je vais vous faire une confidence
ce n'est pas les coûts aujourd'hui qui
hantent ma mémoire c'est tout ce qui va
avec
le nom amour
et sa détestation
et sa volonté de me détruire et pour
cela elle avait une phrase
elle me disait
personne ne veut de toi
c'est difficile de grandir
sans l'amour de ses parents
parce que va nous manquer un truc
fondamental ça va pas nous donner des
ailes pour l'affronter la vie
et puis en 5e au collège
une assistante sociale est venu me voir
après un signalement pour maltraitance
elle a pris très au sérieux mon attitude
d'ado martyrisé et ma difficulté à
m'asseoir sur les boursouflures violette
de mon dos
alors elle a été voir mes parents
elle a vu la grande maison
et la bibliothèque en chêne massif dans
le salon
et ça ne rentrait pas dans la case de
l'enfance maltraitée
alors elle n'a pas fait de signalements
et elle n'a pas suivi
le problème de la maltraitance c'est
souvent ça vous éloigne des études
et il ya une case qui vous attend quand
on fait pas d'études elle s'appelle la
précarité
remarquez on n'y est pas tout seul dans
la précarité n'est croise plein de gens
dans la précarité que moi j'ai connu
si j'avais suivi les cases de cette
précarité là
j'aurais pu finir droguée
prostituée
ou encore morte
et puis à 19 ans
j'ai déclenché un cancer
un rare
un qui en général pointe le bout de son
nez au moment de la ménopause
alors cette fois ci
c'était pas la bonne case mais parce que
c'était pas le bon timing
j'avais pourtant voulu faire comme tout
le monde
des études
avoir un super job
faire un prêt pour une maison
me marier
avoir des enfants
et adopter un chien
mais dans la rue
ma seule préoccupation
c'était survivre
il y a quand même quelque chose que j'ai
réussi à faire à peu près comme tout le
monde ses deux enfants alors qu'on me
disait que je ne pourrai jamais en faire
deux garçons à 15 ans d'intervalle sur
de rechute de cancer est seul
alors ok c'est pas tout à fait comme
tout le monde on est d'accord
pour mon 1er hugo tout avait très bien
commencé un magnifique bébé brun avec
tous ses doigts
jusqu'à ce jour de mars 2005
où je suis dans le service de pédiatrie
génétique et on m'annonce que mon petit
garçon de 5 ans
souffre d'une maladie génétique rare
appelée syndrome de l'x fragile
on me dit que mon petit garçon de 5 ans
ne pourra plus marcher à l'adolescence
qu'il est débile et qu'il ne pourra pas
suivre une scolarité normale
tout à l'heure je vous parlais de la
précarité et de ne pas rentrer dans des
cases
il ya une chose qui fait qu'on n'est pas
comme tout le monde sait qu'on est libre
je vous parlais aussi des clichés parce
que rentrer dans les cases c'est
correspondre à des clichés des a priori
qui peuvent avoir la vie dure
et la généticienne
ne me croiras pas quand je lui dirai que
pendant ma grossesse je n'ai vu ni
alcool ni pris de drogue
parce qu il est bien évident que quand
on est une mère célibataire de 23 ans et
qu'on est responsable d'animation dans
un grand hôtel en grèce forcément c'est
la fête en bois on se drogue
et ça elle pensera que monfils a subi
mon alcoolisme gestationnel et c'est
écrit dans son dossier médical vous la
voyez la case
je refuse
les préconisations de la mdph maison de
la personne et du handicap
je refuse qu'il aille en ime institut
médico éducatif
et par dessus tout je refuse sa perte
d'autonomie
alors
j'ai choisi la liberté
pour lui et pour moi
les chemins de traverse
l'école comme tout le monde le sport le
beau
et le merveilleux
et j'ai fait la guerre
et j'ai mangé de la maîtresse d'école
tous les matins au petit déjeuner
l'école c'est un cadre extrêmement
limité
j'ai une pensée particulière ce soir
pour cet inspecteur de l'éducation
nationale qui en cp m'avait dit à propos
de d'une demande de soutien scolaire
brugot
je m'oppose personnellement à ce que
votre fils bénéficient de ce soutien
scolaire car je n'ai jamais rencontré de
parents qui en font autant que vous vous
prenez donc la place de quelqu'un qui
n'en fait pas autant
il fallait qu'ils soient valides et pour
lutter contre ça il fallait qu'ils
marchent 30 minutes par jour
alors on a été adopté un chien pas
n'importe lequel un rescapé comme nous
un montagne des pyrénées de 47 kg avec
un coeur noir sur le derrière
j'ai changé de voiture on a pris un
break
et puis
j'ai poussé tirer
crier engueuler mon fils
et j'ai hurlé pleuré et ri comme jamais
avec les grâce à lui
il est clair que si nous avions suivi
les chemins tout tracés si nous étions
rentrer dans les cases il ne serait
jamais arrivé là où il est
il a choisi de faire du sport beaucoup
de sport avant de trouver le sien y les
judokas
alors c'est sûr qu'avec les problèmes de
motricité de coordination et la vision
qui est génial le squash le badminton ou
encore le ping pong c'est un peu d
everest pour lui et pourtant il a adoré
pratiques et les trois
aujourd'hui mon fils qui est là parmi
vous il a 21 ans
et je suis immensément fier de lui
il est valide
et il a réussi son bac tout seul sans
aucune adaptation
alors bien sûr j'ai appris tout c'est le
sont avec lui et j'ai réécrit tous ses
cours
et puis à 35 ans
j'ai passé mon bac
et je les ai eus avec mention
et puis est arrivé mon second enfant
adrien
après un combat épique
hémorragie coma et cetera
vous vous dites sans doute c'est pas
commun tout ça et rassurez vous parce
que moi je me disais pareil
et la vie semble devenir
normale enfin presque
adrien grandit
et on me dit ce serait bien de faire
tester son intelligence
et puis à chaque fois qu'on m'en parle
je pleure
je pleure vous comprenez à cause de la
case
je mets deux ans avant d'aller chez une
europe si pour le faire tester
bilan
adrien et h pays au potentiel
intellectuel
alors voilà
il est différent
ça recommence
vous vous dites sans doute
que j'ai à peu près coché toutes les
cases
presque et que je suis rentré dans
aucune des caves
pourtant
j'ai connu la maltraitance la violence
les abus de toutes sortes
la maladie
le handicap
l'absence de diplôme
et le nom amour
vous savez quoi il ya une case qui me
tendaient les bras c'est la case de
victimes
et c'est la seule case dans laquelle
j'ai jamais voulu rentrer j'ai jamais
voulu être une victime
aujourd'hui j'ai 45 ans
et ma vie est merveilleuse
et avec mes deux avengers
les animaux à cinq pattes on a notre
propre gaz
aujourd'hui j'ai 45 ans et je suis enfin
et et mais comme je suis
ma vie est faite d'amour de joie et
d'émerveillement
j'ai une gratitude infinie
parce que je suis en vie
vous avez sans doute compris quand et
chacun différents
et vous
a quelle case vous conformez vous
merci
[Applaudissements]